pre-civilian population
Although there is information that there may be
soldiers there, but we have
not yet lifted a single body from the ground, and as for the
raisin, about 50 civilians in the territory of the
Kharkiv region were
found this week. We are not talking
about mass burials, which we
will still have to do  to raise the bodies from there, unfortunately,
it is similar to the Bloody series after Buchi,
we see
pictures and in other de-occupied regions of
our country, in Izyum, they know. They have
found
dead people from the security forces, but there are also
separate
burials of
many tortured people, a
total of seven  'holes in one or another
on one or another territory, this is the city of
Kupyansk, 6 citizens of Sri Lanka studied at the local medical college,
and these same 6 citizens do not know
English, one speaks English, and
when the
enemy troops entered the city of Kupyansk,
they tried to leave  they did not have time to reach the city of Kharkiv, the
occupiers
detained them and took them to the city of Vovchansk,
now these Sri Lankan citizens find  are
in the city of Kharkiv in safety, they give
evidence, well, first of all, their
psycho-emotional state causes
concern because they are scared,
they abused them in any way
40 investigators of the national police 10
forensic laboratories
representatives
[music] of the
medical examination in the territory of the
mass burial of our citizens
approx.  At the moment, there are 445
burials of the nature of the nature of the
injuries, the causes of death, we will already
establish this work, I will say right away, not
for one week, it is a painstaking work, the
appropriate equipment came up, this
excavator, cars of the
corpse, you understand, these bodies
have been buried there since March,
next to me, I draw your attention  this is a whole
family, this is a young family, the father was born in 88, the
wife was born in 91, their little
daughter was born in 2016, and their
parents.
the number is bodies and tied hands
p  behind each This fact will be
investigated and given the proper right to
this assessment, but accordingly it can only
indicate that the world really must recognize that
this is indeed a fact of genocide of our
Ukrainian people there, our investigative actions are
related to the exhumation of bodies regarding the
number of available operational data, which
amount to 500 of
at the present time,
due to the large volume and
procedural complexity of the procedure, we
can count maybe 40
exhumed bodies. This is the maximum investigative
action we can take to remove bodies, record the possible
consequences of violent
death and send them for a
forensic medical examination.  for a more
detailed review